en fin de compte je vais vous le faire
je vais vous faire la saint-jacques
celsius purée de framboises vinaigrée au
château d'amboise un concept pour vous
mettre les papilles en émoi
le principe est simple vous faites votre
marché directement sur les stands des
producteurs
une fois vos produits sélectionnés c'est
un chef qui devant vous ce tube de
mitonner votre plat j'ai amené des
purées de purée de champignons
légèrement truffé j'ai des purées de
salsifis
donc moi j'attends que les gens
m'apportent quelque chose et
spontanément mais on leur fait quelque
chose alors l'aiguillette tout à l'heure
que j'ai préparé pour certaines
personnes ben je suis sûr que si tout à
l'heure j'en ai une autre qui me ramène
des aiguillettes je vais faire encore
autre chose
quelle bonne surprise on se sent
parfaitement privilégiées on apprend on
essaye de retenir il va falloir prendre
des notes prendre des notes et bien
saisir tous les conseils du chef ici la
saint-jacques est préparé avec de la
salle tus un légume aujourd'hui oubliée
c'est une laitue qui a particularité de
faire une très grande tige qui va monter
jusqu'à 40 50 cm de hauteur il en existe
des centaines de variétés c'est
d'origine chinoise
c'est très chlorophyllien ça a vraiment
un goût de sève de salade
voilà c'est c'est assez neutre mais
c'est la texture qui est vraiment très
intéressant on a de la chance pour le
déguster
il faut débarrasser ce légume de ces
fibres pour ne garder que le coeur il
reste maintenant à l'accommoder en
salade ou bien chaud comme ici avec des
noix de saint jacques
le cru là c'est fabuleux un parfum d'un
concours qui est habituel et puis c'est
presque nous pour moi c'est une
nouveauté goy donc une découverte c'est
cuisine éphémère installée sur les
terrasses du château royal d'amboise ont
ravi beaucoup de visiteurs une ode à
l'art de vivre à la française